wunderschöne vormittag liebe
sportfreunde ja wohl jetzt geht es los
wir treffen uns hier zum ersten von fünf
online trainings was machen wir was
bieten wir heute am ersten tag machen
wir einen intermittierenden rumpf kraft
zirkel gemeinsam das heißt jetzt
komplizierter an wie es tatsächlich dann
ist das ist einfach eine rumpf übung
kombiniert mit bewegung bis am stand
laufen urspringen handball man was auch
immer gerade einfällt ja morgen mein
kraft ausdauertraining mit dem eigenen
körpergewicht das bauma auf das ganze
bis hin zum freitag muss man das ganze
dann mit einem entsprechenden
regenerations- und denen training
beenden
solltet ihr fragen haben zu dem
sportlichen aspekt zu dem workout unser
leitern der sportwissenschaftler aus dem
jahre sportzentrum der dr wolfgang
rausch sitzt vor dem pc und wartet
gespannt auf deine fragen
und wie gesagt nicht scheuen diese
einfach stellen gemeinsam schaffen wir
es wir kommen fit aus dem lokal und die
wird sagen genug der worte
wir beginnen mit dem gemeinsamen
aufwärmen der nikkei schloss einmal am
stand laufen wir fangen an wir bringen
den kreislauf ganz locker in schwung
müssen schauen dass das herz kreislauf
system etwas angeregt wird das kann man
natürlich variieren man kann schneller
laufen kann langsamer lassen
man kann koordinative aspekte mit knie
heben mit anfassen wie gesagt der
fantasie sind hier keine grenzen gesetzt
anfangs haben wir entsprechend anfangen
es zu tun ist einmal das allerwichtigste
wer das laufen dann schon vielleicht ein
bisschen zu viel wird der kann am stand
gehen das ist alles kein thema so dass
einfach in bewegung setzt ist das ganzes
wichtige ja wohl dass man sagen wir kurz
mit am stand laufen wichtig auch
entsprechend die gelenke zu mobilisieren
wir fangen an mit dem becken kreisen das
heißt nach links nach rechts im labor
wiederholungen einer der wichtigsten
punkte eben wir trainieren den rumpf
müssen entsprechend den rumpf auf wir
haben das heißt alles rund um die
wirbelsäule passiert das klärt
entsprechend bewegt das geld
entsprechend
aufgewärmt gehört wir haben aber
varianten große kreise kleine kreise nur
das becken kreisen nach vor zurück nach
links nach rechts doch einfach die
unterschiedlichsten varianten
entsprechend umsetzen
ok jetzt haben wir mobilisiert entlang
von der wirbelsäule jetzt beginnen wir
wieder zum laufen wir machen da er
bislang wechsel hampelmann springen
jumping jacks entweder die ganze
variante oder die halbe variante das
heißt sie kann mit den händen auf der
hälfte aufhören meine probleme in der
beweglichkeit in der schulter haupt zum
beispiel ist das eine gute variante wie
ich das trotzdem umsetzen kann ik nach
dem ganzen eine koordinative komponente
geben und varianten reinbringen geräte
zeigen wir unterschiedliche varianten
was machst du da wie heißt das gerät
sprung im anstoß genau wir wollen ja und
wir locker wieder kurz aus natürlich
jederzeit möglich ein schluck zu trinken
wenn der mund trocken wird das ist
überhaupt kein thema das ist einer der
wichtigen dinge aber im training ja mal
jetzt kann man zu einer übung das ist
das rumpf drehen in der vorbeuge dann
macht er gerne das ganze frontal wenig
gedreht sie bitte 90 grad zum guerrilla
dass man sie immer wieder die position
im rücken aus schaut ja wohl heute so
mehr beweglichkeit der andere weniger
entweder zu den zehenspitzen hinunter
greifen oder beim knie aufhören beide
varianten gut wir wir haben gemeinsam
auf dann braucht man auch fünf
wiederholungen links und fünf rechts da
kann man mit dem tempo bisserl variieren
der nächste übung wäre was macht boxen
auf ihr wollt klassischen eine
militärische grund fertigkeit der
selbstverteidigung gehört mit dazu
boxen auf alle möglichen schläge der
boxschule gerade hier in der aussagen
zeit wird sagen alles kein problem ist
technisch nicht perfekt ist mittag es
geht ums aufgaben ja auch unsere frauen
boxen sich durch sehr gut
jawohl und aus lauter kreisen
wir haben auch die oberen extremität die
arme mit den schultern das binde gelenk
quasi der ganz stark mit belastet das
heißt es muss mal aufwärmen
wir haben wir daraus schulter kreisen es
gibt zwei varianten volle kreise große
kreise kleine kreise vorwärts rückwärts
mit koordinative komponente eine vor
eine zurück ja auch mit bewegung
natürlich möglich das wird dann immer
schwieriger für einen anfang zum auf wir
haben am kreisen tausend rosen
das haben wir mit dabei jawohl ok
nächste übung in aufgaben prozess dass
die oberkörper rotation
wir drehen den körper hin und her wir
fangen mit kleinen bewegungen an locker
links rechts der kopf geht mit wir
schauen mit und können in der bewegung
immer größer werden diesmal wirklich im
anschlag der beweglichkeit drin und
bitte nicht zu intensiv mit zu viel
schwung hinein fahren in die endposition
sondern das ganze im blick sagt langsam
aufbauen jeder so wie es für ihn
persönlich sich am besten an fügt der
gut aussah was haben wir noch für
variante ihre aufwärmübungen macht man
da
er hat nimmt eine sprung schnur springt
mit der sprung schnell wer keine hat
läuft am stand und besser eine flotte
langsam aus persönlicher erfahrung
aufpassen blumenvasen in sicherheit
bringen uns strom schnur kann einiges
auch zerstören ok ja wohl ein prozess
abgeschlossen dann ja jeder dass er
seine marke hat oder zumindest in sein
handtuch auf dem man sich abstützen kann
an schluck trinken ja wohl nicht
gewinnen ist natürlich auch gerne dass
der mund trocken ist wichtig
flüssigkeitszufuhr beim training wir
starten jetzt mit unserem workout für
dieses workout haben wir folgende zeit
die man trainieren und wir uns bewegen
aber noch niemand 30 sekunden rhythmus
30 sekunden nach nur eine übung 30
sekunden bewegen und noch einmal noch
einmal 30 sekunden also in summe 90 wo
ich die nächste übung mit einem von den
zweien vorzeige ja die die von euch
wirklich stark sondern die zeit gas
geben wohin dieses nächste die nächsten
20 minuten die können die zweiten 30
sekunden natürlich auch gern durch
bewegen
das ist alles im bereich des möglichen
und wie gesagt wenn sie von der
belastung her zu viel wird da
selbstständig einfach die ein oder
andere sekunde von der übungszeit
abzubiegen ist für jeden belastend seien
aber für niemanden überlastet sein ok am
antworten tatsächlich in der zeit
gestaltung wenn ihr sowie erheblicher
anteil herunterlädt und entsprechend da
an rhythmus 30 sekunden durchlaufend
einstellt das ganze mache jetzt ganz
schnell dass man 30 sekunden dann
tatsächlich genau einhalten können so
bereit machen
ich zähle von drei herunter und dann
startet man den countdown ok 3 2 1 los
ja wohl countdown läuft die ersten 30
sekunden nehmen noch zum erklären der
ersten übung der ihm offen bitte wird
zwar den unter
jawohl unterstützt wichtig die arme sind
parallel der kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule ich habe eine spannung aus
dem bauch heraus aus dem rumpf heraus
die chinesen durchgestreckt und von
schulter hüftgelenk und sprunggelenk
hatte ich ungefähr eine gerade wir haben
noch fünf sekunden bitte in die
opposition bereit machen 321 und
übungszeit läuft und für alle die diese
jetzt gedanken machen um meine um unsere
gesundheit meine lieben wir sind alle
kroner negativ getestet wir dürfen den
engen kontakt haben kein problem wir
testen jeden tag in der früh also von
dem wir sagen wir mal ganz ganz toll was
können wir die variante übung
erleichtern nicht wie kriegen was
leichter hin
die knie auf den boden dann hat man
kürzeren hebel gary und bei dir wie
können wir schwerer machen stehen die
strecke beine abwechselnd hochheben zeit
ist um auf und wir bewegen uns jetzt
zeit verstreichen lassen zu bewegen
[Applaus]
genau und jetzt wie gesagt nur springen
das möglichkeit der volkslauf was
möglichkeit da ahnte man dass
möglichkeit der hat so viele
verschiedene varianten und wenn es
notwendig ist auch den anstands laufen
am stand alles drinnen
wir haben noch 321 nicht bewegt sich
weiter gegenseitig zeigen die nächste
übung vor
derzeit steht auf der linken seite da
setzte wieder die linie zwischen der
virushülle kopf gerade über das becken
über die über das bein ist wieder eine
ebene eine gerade wichtig ist dass der
seitliche braucht gespannt ist dahinter
angespannt ist und die entsprechenden
druck da halten kann
eine leichtere variante wäre was nie
anwesend und 90° 21 oder selten daraus
alle arbeiten alle sind in der übung
nicky hayden hat bisschen schwerer
machen für die die jetzt sagen das ist
eigentlich vorstag hinterlassen
genau deine hochheben handwerk strecken
eine variante zweite variante becken
heben und senken und wie gesagt wenn es
zu viel ist der kurze heber entsprechend
auch eine variante 90 grad im kniegelenk
dann kann ich das auch noch dynamisch
machen so 1 aus 30 sekunden sind dabei
es beginnt die nächste bewegungsphasen
kicker beim training alles gute vampire
sich mit der punkt aus dem olympischen
boxen da ist natürlich die schnur
springen und der boxer lauf oder
schattenboxen eine variante mit der nasa
sehr gut diese bewegungszeit verbringen
kann
jäger nachdem du das so perfekt machst
machst keine zweiten 30 sekunden bitte
weiter und die nächste variante seid
stolz rechte seite zeige ich mit wenig
entgehen wie wegen ja oder art kurze
pause machen wir mal wir haben auf der
zweiten seite ganz das gleiche wir
schauen dass man das becken leicht vor
drehen dass man die anspannung wirklich
schön seitlich im bauch drehen spüren
ich kann das an euro wenn es zum
abstützen zum beispiel seitlich am
dresdner zoo wirtschaft eine position
dabei eine wählen dass sie mit beiden
beinen abstützt genau und in 32 jährige
los 130 sekunden übungszeit seid stets
auf der rechten seite ihr kennt es
bereits wir haben die schweren varianten
die leichten varianten gesucht die aus
die für euch am besten funktioniert und
20 sekunden übungszeit von nur 15
sekunden halbzeit erreicht durchbeißen
wieder gleich drei varianten schwere
variante
ja wo ich gerne wie schon zuletzt beim
jährige tage und wir bewegen uns wieder
geht schon aus wie gesagt kinder jedes
militärisches workout kann liegestütz
rein
doch während man heute eine abgeänderte
variante rücklings machen das aus der
box schaut nach oben
das wird die nächste variante sein thema
gemeinsam machen werden der libysche
zurück links entsprechend mit becken
heben und senken wenn man die belastung
noch steigern möchte
wir haben noch drei sekunden 21 und
zeigen die nächste übung vorherigen wir
zwar liege stets rücklings fersen sind
am boden becken ist in der luft hintern
ist ein gespannter kompletten ja wohl
nur stieg weiter auf jetzt sehen ja
schultern fingerspitzen schauen zurück
der blick ist nach oben das heißt die
heiß wirbelsäule ist wieder gerade
das ist die ausgangsposition und für die
übung selbst kann jetzt das becken heben
und senken und jemand der es wirklich
wissen will kann auch die beine
wechselweise hochheben so ein zurzeit
fast übersehen allem hedge fonds nicht
dafür bieten wir jetzt war zeigen die
abgeschwächte variante vor die etwas
leichtere variante
das heißt das becken heben dass die
fersen sind am bodensee in scheinen die
luft und das becken ablegen und wieder
hoch heben das ist ein bisserl lockere
variante wenn die spannung über die
gesamte länge noch nie so gut halten
kann
da kann es nur noch ein bisschen
schwerer machen indem ich die hände nach
oben strecke der hobby mehrere
möglichkeiten eben das entsprechend zu
variieren
30 sekunden sind dabei oft bewegen
[Applaus]
nur springen natürlich eine gute ware
handlung das herz-kreislauf-system
schwung zu bringen
meine des nord perfekt beherrschen der
schnur springen dann wird es richtig
richtig anstrengend sein mag so biete
ausreichend hause das heißt natürlich
die nächsten dreißig sekunden
entsprechend etwas weniger hatten
vielleicht nur gehen am stand freilich
vorbei nicht wir zwei tagen die nächste
übung vor das heißt musik tabs zu jedem
rumpf training kern sieht das dazu ich
habe die schwere variante die hände bei
der schläfe bitte ja nicht heimlich
hinten verschränkung weil sonst ziehe
ich mich mit meinem entlang vom kopf
wieder hoch wirklich seitlich zum kopf
ergeben die hände
etwas leichter die hände vor der brust
und noch ein bisserl weniger spannung
die hände in vorhalte restrukturiert
ganz gut 30 sekunden worker zeit jetzt
so wichtig dabei die fersen bleiben am
boden wenn sie die fersen weggeben von
boden ist die übung zu schwierig dann
bitte mit den händen variieren so wie
man es vorher gehabt haben bei der
schläfe fordert rust oder in vorhalten
was spürbar nikki schreurs okay da kann
man eine variante einbauen radfahrer im
liegen oder 30 sekunden sind vorbei wir
gehen wieder in die bewegung hinein
wir haben uns beim boxen immer
hochgezogen die eigene deckung über
nachlässiger wichtiger aspekt noch wenig
gesehen sehr gut und wir haben es fast
durch den ersten durchgang sechs übungen
von sieben hammer eine übung was man
auch dann machen wir kurzes jahren pause
zu hause und dann machen wir das ganze
ein zweites mal noch teile so gerne wir
zwar die brücke
und ja natürlich weiter bewegen aber die
nicht bewegt ja also wie kannst du sagen
jawoll füße am boden hände am boden her
in die fingerspitzen schauen wieder nach
hinten becken hinter angespannt schön
hoch kopf wieder in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule
und das variante das bein heben
wechselweise wichtig dabei schauen dass
das becken nicht weg gibt links oder
rechts sondern schön stabil bleibt wird
schon aus 30 sekunden für alle
ich kann dem ganzen natürlich auch eine
gewisse dynamische komponente zusätzlich
eingehen mit becken heben und senken und
die kann hat die zwar übungen jetzt
kombinieren
indem ich bete das becken heben und
senken und gleichzeitig das bein
wechseln wieder hin und her
und ja zehn sekunden ab so durchbeißen
letzte übung im ersten satz 3 1
arme bewegen und dann geht sind diese
jahren pause gehts los
ich würde vorschlagen jetzt bewegen uns
alle haben wir eine minute lang das
heißt 50 sekunden ab jetzt und dann hör
mal gemeinsam auf und macht unsere pause
wer möchte kann natürlich auch anstand
gehen flott gehen laufen gibt
unterschiedlichste varianten zu nehmen
haben wenn man auch die ersten 30
sekunden hatte volle fälligen schafft
von der minute bewegung musik kann
natürlich passieren deswegen haben wir
die touren schauen dass man mit den
zeilen dass die tschechen haben bucht
uns die kunden noch 5 4 3 2 1
ja wohl heute die ersten ersten
durchgang mannschaft der erste durchgang
ist vorbei ihr kennt euch gern
niedersetzen durchschnaufen und schluck
trinken
wie war es von der anstrengung
herausgegangen oder ja also man dagegen
aufstand war es wahrscheinlich richtig
von der intensität der nahe liege kein
leichtes stück ein teil von der
belastung her wie es jesus fragt das
heißt mit mehr bewegen mit weniger
bewegung deshalb schicken leute ein
wichtiger punkt den ich in dieser stelle
noch mitgeben möchte ist wir ja das
hehre sportzentrum wir trainieren
einsatzsoldaten und wir persönlich wir
trainieren aber wie einsatz zutaten die
es in unserem vorstand video gesehen mit
caterpillar mit sand bikes mit gewichts
gruppen mit allem was dazu erklärt wir
versuchen jetzt hier des trainings
soweit herunterzubrechen dass jedes der
hama gut umsetzen kannst ohne
zusätzliche hilfsmittel das war ein ganz
wichtiger punkt vielleicht dass sie
nicht da jetzt das bei ausländern wirst
und irgendwas da
da haben zu recht schließt sondern dass
wir einfach so wie es ist mitmachen
könnt ok ja ja exakt das erste training
haben wir zur hälfte was kommt morgen
morgen kommt ein entsprechender
kraftausdauer zirkel wo man belasten und
base machen dass wir das der inhalt von
michael tag sind und noch eine
erinnerung der doktor aus sitzt vorm
computer antwortet auf eure fragen
jederzeit bitte gerne stellen und
beantworten überzeugen einen schluck
trinken in 30 sekunden geht es nämlich
wieder los zwei dadurch können die
übungen sind bekannt ihr wisst was
braucht motivation und bekommt jetzt
wieder uns gemeinsam in zehn sekunden
gebe es wieder an
wir fahren mit bewegen die schlauen
genau 32 16
[Applaus]
im ergster kreislauf wieder drauf die
kurze pause hat uns nicht geschadet
sein herz schlage sofort wieder oben
viele kleine gerät direkt mit dem
nächsten mit dem nächsten durchgang
beginnen
märz nachweisen konnten künftig 31 als
die ersten 30 sekunden vorbei und du
darfst dir ruhig weiter bewegen sich ja
da wäre das weiter bewegen welche
voreilig gewesen
die nici und die machen wieder die erste
übung den unterhalt stück ich wiederhole
noch mal ganz wichtig da kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule spannung
aus der wirbelsäule aus der muskulatur
sowohl von becken wie auch vom rücken
dahinter ist angespannt die knie sind
gestreckt und ich habe eine schöne
gerade zwischen schultern bedecken und
wir alle immer noch der anstieg geht
schon los
die nimmt sie gleich die schwere
variante mit bein heben jawohl 30
sekunden die haare wie geht's dir sagst
da kannst du gleich dazu wahnsinn hier
mal gesagt schauen das becken stabil
bleibt und nicht weg gibt ja wohl schon
anspannen das ist ganz wichtiger
vielleicht haben die spanier verlieren
und wenn es von der belastung her bis
sie zu viel wird dann nehmt euch einfach
den kurzen hebel glücklich hier im boden
30 die potenziale länger wieder in die
bewegung hinein
das hätte gerne einmal dass man mal alle
varianten der bewegung entstand durch
machen wir haben den boxer laufen den
hamburgern bereits gegen den standort
box oder vor sommer neu gewählte stoss
mit anschlüssen wie sagst
gerät sprung mit anstoßen aber nicht
genau was sprechen springer gut machen
wir die zweiten 30 sekunden
die konstruktion ihres zeichens wenig
gesprengt 30 sekunden dann haben wir
tatsächlich alle varianten durch okay
wir geben es da wieder eine und eine
variante mehr dazu das heißt die
hauptstadt wo er den bauch anspannen
muss dahinter ist angespannt wir keins
das becken heben und senken um das ganze
viel schwerer zu machen
bei jeder variante ist der kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule
das heißt immer gerade dass man keine
probleme aus der nacken wirbelsäule
bekommen so 1 zeit ist aus wickie kommt
dazu und tempo geht los wenn die
bewegung zu schwer wird wenn die übung
zu schwer wird und die im becken weg
gibt nehme einfach eher leichtere
variante genauer gesagt dass eva ich
kann auch bei der variante das bein mit
mitnehmen heben und senken ja alles kein
problem solange der hintern anstand ist
und ich scheider spannung in der
rumpfmuskulatur habt kann es nicht so
verkehrt sein okay das ganze natürlich
statisch und dynamisch möglich beide
varianten hamada 30 kunden so 1 und
bewegen
du bist um drei sekunden zu aufstanden
das nächste mal gucken ja gut los dass
ein gerade wieder kleiner börsenschluss
bringen ganz gerne
das erinnern was war den extrakt links
frost recht genau
und dann mag man gleich wieder gemeinsam
mit 32 19 jährige springt weiter zu
sagen was ist wichtig dass bei einer
sich das heißt leute die jetzt man vom
geräuschpegel schwierig zu hören war
wichtig ist es die höchste stabil bleibt
laut ba so als wenn man hinten gibt und
einer modischen 21 und jahre von dazu 30
sekunden workout für alle zwei jahre
nimmt wieder das bein abgespreizt so
dass für jeden die belastung gut ist ja
da kann man sie da kann man sich einfach
austoben mit winkel im knie decken heben
und senken bei 1 mitnehmen nicht
ausfallschritt quasi ein beinahe vorher
eines zurück nie gesagt dass vielleicht
noch mal kurz was sie damit meinen dass
beinahe vorzugeben genau dass sie bei
einigen abstütze ist auf 30 sekunden
statt und wir bewegen uns und es bleiben
vier übungen über vier übungen macht man
auch und das workout ist vorbei ja also
viermal ja ja das ist kein bock so
wichtig beim schattenboxen guter
standort okay
was kann der laie vormachen
nix ist einfach ne zu machen genau
bewegen und spaß machen bleibt arena bei
mir gerne ja wohl okay wir zeigen das
nächste fohlen liegestütz lieblingstiere
kommt wichtig ich wiederhole es nochmal
die fingerspitzen schauen nach hinten
der kopf ist in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule dahinter nissan stand das
entdecken schon hoch kommt und die
fersen sein am boden
wenn es vom winkel ja so schwierig ist
legen wir dass diese ist ab gehen die
wir gehen und winkeln den beiden ja
danach legte hinterlegt nicht die nach
hinten und drückt das becken hoch 30
sekunden für alle genau das heißt es ist
die zweite variante nicht wie du machst
die anzahl variante genau was haben
gesagt wir kriegen wir das hin dass es
richtig richtig richtig schwer wird wie
er möchte
wir wechseln das bein wir haben immer
eine auflage und wächst unter hin und
her dabei wichtig auch das becken bleibt
stabil
aber die zwei wochen bis er ganz gut ich
glaube das ist nicht das erste mal wo
man wurde dass das trainieren ja ok nach
30 runden 21 frauen wieder belegen die
sprossen als gefährliche täter mit fast
erwischt immer aufpassen
aber ich glaube der war selbst der blog
ja okay was haben wir sagt was haben wir
für einen extern nicht erinnern
wie sieht es richtig die vorletzte
gesichter variante her in der beiden
schläfen vor der brust und im vorhalte
machen wir ja wohl erste variante handy
bei den schläfen zweite variante hände
voller brust dritte variante hin den
vorhalten und gradmesser für die
schwierigkeit wenn die fersen hochheben
beim beim nach oben beim ausrichten
dann ist das von der belastung her zu
schwierig damit die leichtere variante
drei sekunden aber bereit machen gerne
kam dann geht's los und nahm als
erinnerung jederzeit programm und
schluck trinken ja während dem training
die 230 kunden wir nehmen uns so viel
zeit muss sein ja gerade hat noch andere
variante der kombinierte sie tabs mit
dem becken heben das heißt ich habe es
an wechsel zwischen belastung der
bauchmuskulatur und der rückenmuskulatur
wie gesagt es gibt ganz viele varianten
das aller aller wichtigste es überhaupt
zu machen
sich hinzustellen da zu sein und nie zu
trainieren auf unterlegen kann man haben
wenn man die hände vorm wechsel nicht
die hände von wechselt ausfallschritte
genau das ganze gegen gleich einfach um
eine zeitlich eröffnen sondern nach
vorne und nach hinten öffnen und
schließen das neue variante rein bringt
das mit fahrrad wird ja weil sie daheim
kein sprung schnell hat das jedes mal
andere übung darin sind es 3 21 jährige
letzte übung zurückgenommen wir wieder
zusammen beißen deine füße am boden
fersen am boden wenn dieser rechter
winkel zwischen ober und unterschenkel
kind dann angespannt was mit der
immobilie rhynern das becken schön hoch
kommt comcom fingerspitze schauen nach
hinten ja mit den varianten wehrt sich
gegen in der praxis becken heben und
senken eine heben im wechsel möglich so
wichtig wie gesagt aber dann sieht man
dass der kopf bleibt immer in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule auch wenig
bewegung im becken drinnen habe der kopf
bleibt in der verlängerung das bewegt
sie mit der bleibt selber immer hoch und
nieder
leute die letzten zehn sekunden vom
aktiven workout catcher noch 5 4 3 2 1 1
aus wir schließen das ganze mit 30
sekunden bewegung abgeht schloss arme
bewegen
ja das war es das erste workout ist so
gut wie vorbei
ja die bewegt sich beim boxen hat ist
jeder das was er am besten kann ja okay
wir haben noch fünf sekunden bewegen 4 3
2 1 1 aus
danke danke für für das vorzeigen für
das mitmachen
jawohl was machen wir morgen morgen
haben wir wie gesagt einen kraftausdauer
zirkel mit dem eigenen körpergewicht ihr
braucht eure trainingsmatte eine
wasserflasche und ausreichend motivation
ja wohl bei fragen natürlich auch jetzt
noch gerne an den doktor rasch via live
chat und eine erinnerung wo wir haben
auch ein video auf youtube gestellt das
ist ab 16 uhr abrufbar
das heißt ab 16 uhr kennt sie das
workout gern am nachmittag auch noch ein
zweites mal machen beziehungsweise jetzt
den dritten und vierten durchgang jo
weil kann ja wir freuen uns auf morgen
wir machen euch fit zu hause mit dem
workout
danke schön und ich freue mich auf
morgen 10 uhr 30 auf ein wiedersehen